we're going to begin actually with a
tough story out of montana an
investigation into what caused a deadly
derailment in a beautiful stretch of
that state at least three people are
killed dozens more injured in the
accident some cars jumped off the tracks
all of it happened near the town of
joplin it's an amtrak route from chicago
to seattle federal investigators are
there and so is our meg oliver may good
morning as i said this is a gorgeous
part of the country and it was a
beautiful day when this happened mile
for mile rail travel is supposed to be
very safe what happened
tony good morning the liberty county
sheriff said he is still working on
identifying the relatives of those who
died experts say derailments where cars
flip over like this one are incredibly
rare and this comes just days after an
inspection of the tracks in the area
oh my god it's on its side
oh the train's destroyed down there
social media video from survivor showed
the terrifying moments after an amtrak
empire builder train derailed saturday
in north central montana killing at
least three and injuring dozens more
rail cars were tossed on their sides
passengers stranded and luggage
scattered in the wake the westbound
train was on its way from chicago to
seattle when it derailed near joplin
montana it was carrying approximately
141 passengers and 17 crew members i was
laying down in my in my compartment on a
bed so luckily i just tumbled
just in the room andrew savula was
headed from chicago to portland i heard
a loud bang
and then the cars tipped wayne freed was
switching cars when the derailment
happened i was lucky and that i
was able to grab a hold of the coffee
table and i just held on to that and my
legs were dangling down below and the
windows broke out down below and which
is how we eventually escaped after the
train stopped there were routine
inspections just days before this
tragedy on the tracks this section of
track was last inspected on september
23rd as part of bnsf's regular
inspection program former ntsb chairman
robert sumwalt says the tracks will be
just one area of focus in the
investigation so if you were on the
ground here what would you be looking
for they'll be looking at three primary
things they'll be looking at the
operation of the train
was the locomotive engineer properly
controlling the train what is the
condition of the track is there anything
about the track itself that could have
led to a derailment and finally the
mechanical condition of the train was
there anything with the train that could
have led to a
derailment ntsb says once they determine
what caused this accident they are
committed to taking action to prevent
anything similar in the future somewhat
also tells me investigators will be
looking at what led to the injuries and
fatalities and whether seat belts could
have prevented them nate
meg thank you